HBO Max just dropped its year-ender teaser,
giving fans a glipmse of what to expect to
see in 2022 on HBO.
Epic lineup through 2022 included many popular
shows, including a tease of the upcoming Game
of Thrones prequel series, House of the Dragon.
Let's take a look:
It shows a new animated logo for House of
the Dragon with an additional confirmation
of its release, the year of 2022.
What is House of the Dragon?
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
House of the Dragon will begin filming at
the beginning of 2021 and will air sometime
in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
It is the main reason Martin did not yet finish
the Winds of Winter book as he postponed writing
Winds of Winter to write Fire And Blood because
they knew this would be a material for a Game
of Thrones successor show.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Later
seasons however, will be based on George RR
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book that will continue with Queen Rhaenyra's
son King Aegon lll reign, and will include
Blackfyre rebellion and go all the way to
the end of the Targaryen dynasty, to Robert’s
Rebellion, including the rebellion itself.
“If you’d like to know a bit more of what
the show will be about… well, I can’t
actually spill those beans,” Martin teased
in his blog, “but you might want to pick
up a copy of two anthologies I did with Gardner
Dozois, Dangerous Women, and Rogues and then
move on to Archmaester Gyldayn’s history,
Fire & Blood.”
Dangerous Women includes what press materials
describe as a “35,000-word novella” by
Martin called “The Princess and the Queen,
or, the Blacks and the Greens,” which is
“about the Dance of the Dragons, the vast
civil war that tore Westeros apart nearly
two centuries before the events of A Game
of Thrones.”
The Greens were the faction during the Dance
of the Dragons that supported the claim of
Aegon ll Targaryen, their rivals being the
Blacks, who supported the claim of Rhaenyra
Targaryen. Both were named for the color of
their clothes worn during one tourney.
Rogues, meanwhile, includes Martin’s story
“The Rogue Prince, or, a King’s Brother,”
which chronicles “the early life, adventures,
misdeeds, and marriages of Prince Daemon Targaryen,”
considered “one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of Ice and Fire.”
Finally, the novel Fire & Blood, released
in November 2018, is the first novel of a
two-part history of the Targaryens in Westeros.
“Centuries before the events of A Game of
Thrones, House Targaryen — the only family
of dragonlords to survive the Doom of Valyria
— took up residence on Dragonstone,” according
to the book’s description on the author’s
site. “Fire & Blood begins their tale with
the legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator
of the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount
the generations of Targaryens who fought to
hold that iconic seat, all the way up to the
civil war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In addition to this, we now know most of the
lead cast, including cast of Daemon, Viserys
and Rhaenyra Targaryen as well as of Alicent
Hightower, further confirming that the main
event of the House of the Dragon will be the
Dance of the Dragons, the Targaryen civil
war.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
I get many questions from fans asking if they
need to even watch the show when they just
finished Fire And Blood book.
The answer is a huge yes.
Not only will there be differences between
the books and the show like it was with Game
of Thrones, but after reading Fire And Blood
book, you still don't know how most of the
events really played out.
Some would think that you could just read
the book Fire & Blood to know what will happen
in the show based on that very same book but
thats far from truth. Why?
Beacuse Fire And Blood is not a nonvencional
novel, it is imaginary history book, and according
to George RR Martin himself, not very accurate
at that.
Because while Fire And blood book was written
by George RR Martin, it wasn't written from
him as facts, but rather through the perspective
of the Citadel's Archmaester Gyldayn who gathered
all the info and as many different sources
as he could and used it to write a book about
the Targaryen history. Some info is fake,
some info is true, some info is semi true.
No one will know for a fact what was happening
in the real history until the House of the
Dragon airs in 2022.
The show unlike the book will contain truth,
it will depict what actually happened, not
the changed history, fake or semi true, not
what might or might not have happened.
Fire & Blood is a complete history of House
Targaryen written by George R. R. Martin from
a perspective of Archmaester Gyldayn who wrote
it many decedes after the events took place.
Sure, most of the main events such as battles
and deaths probably did happen, but as Gyldayn
says it in the books, the full truth about
what happened behind close doors, in the privacy
of stairwells, council rooms, and bedchambers
he does not fully know and he turns to many
different sources which usually differ from
one another.
He looks into the course of chronicles laid
down by Grand Maester Runciter and his successors
and many court documents as well.
Gyldayn looks into accounts written decades
later by the children and grandchildren of
those caught up in the events of these times.
Whilst there are undoubtely of use, so much
time has passed between the event and the
recording that many confusions and contradictions
have inevitably crept in.
Unforutunately this is also true for Gyldayn's
two accounts by firsthand observers that have
come down to him.
Septon Eustace who served in the royal sept
in the Red Keep during much of this time and
spent much time as a confidant and confessor
to King Viserys and his queens. His account
is biased, favoring Aegon II over Rhaenyra.
Second account is based upon the verbal account
of the court fool Mushroom who was present
at court for all of them; for King Viserys,
Princess and Queen Rhaenyra and both King
Aegons, the Second and the Third.
During his reign, King Baelor I Targaryen
had Mushroom's book burned on account of its
scandalous content.
There are several main sources for historical
information on the Dance of the Dragons, which
are frequently at odds with each other.
Gyldayn also uses source written by Grand
Maester Orwyle, who had served King Aegon
II Targaryenon his council and was arrested
by the forces of Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen
when she took the city. Orwyle wrote his account
while locked away in the black cells. Uncertain
about whether or not he would survive the
war, he attempted to paint himself in the
best light possible.
Grand Maester Munkun's The Dance of the Dragons,
A True Telling was based on Orwyle's account.
Using all these sources which often differ
from each other, archmaester Gyldayn wrote
his work, Fire And Blood, his work about the
history of House Targaryen.
This format brings up Martin's major thematic
point about the uncertainty of memory, and
history being written by the winners. Neither
side truly won the war, and the decades after
the war, both sides wrote their own biased
history books trying to put their actions
in a better light. Histories written by the
Greens depict Aegon II in good light and Rhaenyra
in bad.
On the other hand, histories written by the
Blacks do the otherwise.
We will know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show comes out, and thats
why you cannot just read Fire And Blood book
and think you would know what actually happen
or what will happen on the show. Books are
written by Archmaester decades and decades
after the events happened, using many sources
that in most cases are very different from
each other and most of them are biased as
well.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Both of them thought they belonged on the
Iron Throne. When people started declaring
for one of them or the other, their fight
divided the kingdoms in two. Targaryens fought
Targaryens, bothers fought brothers, dragons
fought dragons. By the time it was over, thousands
were dead. The conflict would prove to be
incredibly destructive for not only House
Targaryen, but large parts of Westeros as
well. In addition, it devastated the Targaryen's
dragon population, ultimately leading to their
extinction within a few decades.
They never truly recovered.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself.
The show won't jump straight into the fighting,
it will start with a few episodes of the prelude
to the Targaryen civil war, with King Viserys
l likely dying after a few episodes, which
is just enough to introduce us with all the
characters and which side they support as
the future heir, as well as to set up all
the animosity at the court.
King Viserys I Targaryen had three children
by his first queen, Aemma Arryn, but only
one, Princess Rhaenyra, survived to adulthood.
Lacking a son to succeed him, Viserys began
to train Rhaenyra to be his heir, named her
his heir and Rhaenyra soon acquired a support
of hundreds of lords and landed knights.
The king remarried in 106 AC, this time to
Alicent Hightower, and had four more children:
Aegon, Helaena, Aemond, and Daeron.
In 111 AC, a great tourney was held at King's
Landing on the fifth anniversary of Viserys's
marriage to Alicent. During the opening feast,
Queen Alicent wore a green gown, while Princess
Rhaenyra dressed in the red and black of House
Targaryen. Note was taken, and soon all of
Rhaenyra's supporters started wearing black
clothing, while all of Alicent's followers
started wearing green. Over the years, the
popular names applied to both factions were
inspired by the colors they wore: Rhaenyra's
supporters were called "the Blacks", and Aegon
II's supporters were called "the Greens".
Viserys I strengthened Rhaenyra's place in
the succession by marrying her in 114 AC to
Ser Laenor Velaryon - who himself had Targaryen
blood through his mother, Princess Rhaenys.
Rhaenyra gave birth to three sons—Jacaerys,
Lucerys, and Joffrey Velaryon—during her
marriage, although there were rumors that
the father of these princes was not Laenor,
but Ser Harwin Strong. After Laenor was murdered
in Spicetown in 120 AC, Rhaenyra married her
uncle, infamous Rogue Prince, Prince Daemon
Targaryen, younger brother to Viserys I. Her
sons by him were Aegon the Younger—called
so to distinguish him from his uncle, Alicent's
Aegon, who on occasion was called Aegon the
Elder—and Viserys.
The relationship between Rhaenyra and Alicent
declined early in Alicent's marriage to Viserys,
since both ladies had been trying to be the
realm's first lady, and there could only be
one. Alicent's father, Ser Otto Hightower,
had also disliked Rhaenyra's second husband,
Prince Daemon, since the beginning of Viserys's
reign.
The war began when King Viserys I died. His
designated heir for many years had been his
only surviving child by his first wife, his
daughter Rhaenyra. Since Viserys I later remarried,
however, and had several younger children
by his second wife, Alicent Hightower, the
eldest of which was Rhaenyra's half-brother
Aegon II. The Seven Kingdoms had never had
a Ruling Queen before, and many were troubled
by the thought of Rhaenyra succeeding to the
throne. By the inheritance laws of the Andals,
a younger brother succeeds ahead of an elder
daughter, but the Targaryens had never formalized
royal inheritance laws for their new realm
after the War of Conquest 130 years before.
Viserys I, however, had extracted oaths of
fealty from the major lords of the realm that
Rhaenyra would succeed him.
The same day that Viserys I died, Aegon II's
followers, the Greens, staged a coup, and
he was soon crowned in King's Landing. Rhaenyra,
as the Princess of Dragonstone, had her powerbase
on Dragonstone island, where she responded
by being crowned queen by Daemon and declaring
Aegon a traitor.
Aegon II's main supporters were his mother
Alicent's family, the powerful House Hightower
that rules Oldtown as well as the Lannisters.
Rhaenyra's main supporters were her first
husband's family, House Velaryon, as well
as her mother's family, House Arryn and her
uncle and future husband, the most dangerous
man in the Seven Kingdoms and the most experienced
commander, Daemon Targaryen.
The Blacks were mostly in the northeastern
half of Westeros, while the Greens were mostly
in the southwestern half. Dorne was not yet
part of the realm and remained neutral during
the war. The Blacks included the Arryns, the
Starks, and the Tullys (along with most if
not all of the Riverlords, even the Freys).
The Starks felt bound by honor to remain true
to the fealty oaths they had made to Rhaenyra
when her father was still alive. Major Greens
included the Hightowers and Lannisters. Rhaenyra
had thought the Baratheons would support her,
but in what she saw as a major betrayal they
sided with Aegon II. The Greens faced their
own betrayal, however: they had assumed that
all of the Reach would side with the Greens,
but instead the northern half of the Reach
sided with the Blacks. Even some of the Hightowers'
own direct vassals in the south sided with
the Blacks. The Tyrells remained officially
neutral throughout the war.
The Greens had thought that the Greyjoys would
join them - not realizing that the great wealth
they controlled ironically made them a more
enticing target. Seeing little profit in sailing
all the way to the eastern side of Westeros
to raid the modest lands of the Vale or Dragonstone,
the Greyjoys nominally sided with the Blacks
in order to raid the Lannister-Hightower lands
along the eastern coast.
Despite the Greens controlling the wealthier
lands of Westeros, the Blacks had the advantage
of control of the seas. The Greens only had
the Redwyne Fleet to rely on for naval power,
while - through House Velaryon - Rhaenyra's
forces controlled most of the Royal Fleet.
After the Greyjoys sided with the Blacks,
however, the Iron Fleet tied up the Redwynes
in their raids on the west coast, giving the
Blacks free run of the eastern coast. The
Greens attempted to counter this by allying
with the Kingdom of the Three Daughters (an
alliance of Lys, Myr, and Tyrosh), whose fleet
assaulted Rhaenyra's fleets in the massive
Battle of the Gullet. A third of the Velaryon
fleet was lost, but two thirds of the Three
Daughters fleet was destroyed, and the survivors
withdrew from the rest of the war. Overall,
this meant that despite the Greens' numerical
superiority, they had to slowly struggle to
march their armies over land to attack the
Blacks, instead of being able to quickly move
their larger armies by sea.
After Rhaenyra was crowned Queen by Daemon
at Dragonstone and declared her half brother
traitor, King Aegon II declared Rhaenyra and
Daemon traitors as well. After being persuaded
by his mother, Alicent and sister, Helaena,
Aegon dispatched Grand Maester Orwyle to Dragonstone
with a retinue under a peace banner, offering
Rhaenyra generous terms, but was refused.
The most devastating war in the history of
the Seven Kingdoms then began.
20 major battles, even more smaller battles,
and even more betrayals, turncloaks, and twists.
All of that this Game of Thrones prequel show,
House of the Dragon, brings in 2022.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!